[Music]
got some helpful news for you this
morning starting today Americans can
help fight identity theft by freezing
their credit free of charge at the three
main credit monitoring services just
over a year ago a hack of one of those
credit services Equifax affected nearly
150 million people it exposed personal
information including names Social
Security numbers and birth dates making
people susceptible to the risk of fraud
and identity theft CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger is here with
more on this Jill great to have you at
the table so this is welcome news but I
want to go back to how people responded
to the Equifax hack because only 14% of
Americans froze their credit why did
they do that by only 14 because it's
sort of a hard process so we now know
that there were in some states where it
costs ten to thirty dollars to freeze
and unfreeze your credit but the process
of actually freezing it can involve
getting a pin sometimes involve talking
on the phone with a representative
because their websites went down and so
a lot of people were thwarted in their
effort to try to do this really
important thing which is lock down your
credit file so make sure that no thieves
can get in there and open credit in your
name but again the process was so
onerous that just 14% of people froze
their credit
we saw 150 million people have impacted
by this you would have thought many more
would have frozen so this makes it
cheaper but it doesn't make it easier it
does not make it much easier and I think
that that's going to be a big hurdle
look the onus is on us we the consumers
we are the product here we're not the
client I remember last year so many
people said but I didn't give my
information does not matter if you want
to borrow money you've got to have a
credit file and that credit file really
is yours to protect
freezing is really the most important
step you can take the problem is if you
have to go to three of the different
agencies they'll go through a whole
process and then you have to unfreeze it
if you have to borrow money for a car or
a house or you're a small business owner
it can be a pain in the neck and it is
still a pain in the neck but you still
think it's a good idea to freeze your
account I think it is the best way to
lock things down a lot of people think
oh I'll do a credit alert and that's
just a little bitty step you can take it
can last rep reach up to a
now up from 90 days but it's not a
strong enough protection we're really
trying to encourage you to be
responsible it's your data it's going to
be used however these companies want to
use it in terms of selling it so you've
got to be very careful if you find out
someone's used your personal data to
open a fraudulent account what do you do
the first thing you do go to the FTC
website there is an amazing amount of
information there you've got a file an
affidavit you've got to actually go
through the process you may won't even
want to go to the local police you're
then going to use that information to
lock down your credit file and yes you
must freeze again if you want to borrow
money you can always unfreeze it but
freezing is the best protection you will
find okay it's free but still not that
easy to do not so we will take the free
part do it anyway and I love your
necklace I'm staring at it throughout
the say thank you